[Music]
what's house should we tell tonight
crimson clowns hungry hounds mystical
mirrors lunar locusts how about the
scariest story of them all the tale of
the 2014 midterm election whoo the flip
ru I'm a local politician they say it's
dangerous for people to be motivated to
vote purely by hatred and fear
I say let's find out submitted for the
approval of the midnight society I call
this story he rode the subway in New
York he went bowling Institute a travel
ban voted against preparing America for
pandemics like Ebola mandatory 21-day
quarantine people isn't really that
contagious and it kills way less than
the flu okay fine but there's an old C
terrorists will kill us all
it submitted for the approval of the
midnight society I call this okay fine
you get one story but you can't just use
this as a fear-mongering focus group
this one's really scary
I call it Isis in the woods
their goal is to put a flag in the White
House Isis is a direct threat to the
homeland at least 10 Isis fighters a big
car went across the Mexican border in
Texas this president needs to rise to
the occasion before we all get killed
back here at home she calls it
fear-mongering I call it rational fear
so no fear on Ebola or Isis but what
about both together you know there's an
old bro
at least Faris the adage submitted for
the approval of the midnight society I
call this the Pola infected Mexican Isis
Ebola or Isis or Ebola on the backs of
Isis to come through our border the ISIS
of biological agents unsecured southern
and northern border is that a big part
of this problem I was referring to the
border of the three countries in Africa
there's never been a case of a terrorist
coming across the border okay then
pot legalization on the valley this time
it's the real reefer madness submitted
for the something of the whatever I call
this that the Halloween candy from hell
upstarts buddha fingers sounds funny but
it's downright scary if it ends up in
your child's Halloween stash several
lawmakers pushing the saving kids from
Dangerous Drugs Act sure the only buzz
the kids get is a sugar high the only
buzz kids get is a sugar high marijuana
used by teams like oz has either been
down or unchanged since sweetest Baliga
lized I called this my opponent rapes
and murders people releasing violent
criminals like Evan evil from prison
even when they threatened to kill partly
responsible for the murder of prison
director Tom Clements the lowing
criminals like Nikko Jenkins to be
released early if your family's safe do
voters actually buy this crap hope Stowe
why aren't you guys getting scared this
is scary
I need your belly my face the only thing
we have to fear in this election is you
yeah man come on get out you gotta go
man all right Monticello 2014 sometimes
I wonder why your parents let us hang
out in the woods after midnight you guys
got any weed
[Music]